[Musique]
le soleil se lève à peine sur le mont
blanc et le téléphérique de chamonix et
déjà pris d'assaut en ce début septembre
ce ne sont pas les skieurs qui s'y
précipitent ces deux hommes sont là pour
flirter avec les limites de la pesanteur
et ils sont pressés frédéric puzin ne
tient pas en place
d'accord c'est toujours comme ça mais
c'est parce qu'on est excité tu vois on
l'a on a tellement envie d'y aller
on est content à 2500 mètres d'altitude
c'est au pas de course qu'il gagne le
bord de la falaise pour y enfiler une
étrange tenue ils vont réaliser
l'impensable
on est concentrés parce que bon la
partie on s'équipe le matériel quand
même super important
donc voilà on fait attention à ce qu'on
sait on avait l'impression de ressembler
à quoi là un mois joue ces deux hommes
s'apprêtent à rivaliser avec les oiseaux
ils vont se lancer dans le vide et
réaliser le plus vieux rêve de l'homme
volée
ce qui les fait planer c'est cette
combinaison appelé wingsuit
en anglais
cela signifie combinaison à ailes
grâce à cet équipement il vole à près de
180 km/heure
leur vol s'arrête près de deux
kilomètres plus loin
à l'atterrissage
fred 34 ans et vincent 29 ans sont comme
des gamins oui oh là là là là là tu te
mets pas les moyens de me laisse aller
progressivement ont été déçus quand on
investit nickel et moi je me suis
rapproché tout dix mois pendant la plage
des palmes en effet toute la responsable
il ya une grosse partie de plaisir
c'est hyper intense à c'est le fait
d'être en chute de planer comme ça tu la
montagne de suivre avec les potes
et puis comme enjeu tout se passe super
bien qu'on ouvre à la fin la série c'est
la grosse explosion de loi dès qu'on est
au sol la si c'est pour ça qu'on
recommence volet a toujours été le rêve
de l'homme quitte à prendre tous les
risques
déjà en 1912 le tailleur français franz
reichelt se lance avec son costume
parachute du deuxième étage de la tour
eiffel
[Musique]
il ne s'en relèvera pas ce n'est que 80
ans plus tard que l'homme va réussir à
planer avec une combinaison en 94
le français patrick de gaillarde on
invente le concept de la wingsuit le
phénomène est lancé il va faire le tour
du monde
au fil des années les combinaisons se
perfectionne et permettent de voler au
plus près du sol
[Musique]
l'américain jeff corliss s'amuse même à
raser les rochers
ce jour là cela a failli lui coûter la
vie
il s'en sortira miraculeusement avec les
deux jambes fracturées
ce sport procure une telle montée
d'adrénaline qu'il pousse certains à
dépasser les limites
ces trois derniers mois dans les alpes
six personnes sont décédées
certains étaient des pilotes confirmés
d'autres beaucoup moins expérimenté cela
peut paraître incroyable mais il
n'existe aucune réglementation dans ce
sport extrême
n'importe qui peut s'acheter une
wingsuit sur internet et sauter dans le
vide
mais à moins d'être suicidaire il est
fortement conseillé de s'entraîner au
préalable dans une école de parachutisme
au centre de la réole près de bordeaux
mathieu 17 ans après tu as essayé pour
la première fois une combinaison à ailes
malgré les apparences le jeune homme est
un parachutiste expérimenté il a déjà
effectué plus de 150 saut c'est la
condition indispensable pour s'initier à
la wind qt comme ça faut que ça soit le
plus bas possible
mathieu enfilent une combinaison pour
débutants position la surface entre les
jambes est réduite et ses bras ne sont
pas entièrement pris dans le pti sion
contrairement à son instructeur fabien à
l'ouverture je peux pas aller plus haut
si c'est lui il ya deux surfaces ça vole
et plus du coup c'est avec instable des
plus compliqués à voler voilà on a vite
fait de prendre une gamelle équipements
alors qu'ils avaient les combinaisons
comme ça qu'ils sont peu vache est à 6
euros la chtouille a presque plus d'
influence de la combinaison son envol tu
vois la différence
niveau 1 niveau de la méthode pour se
diriger dans les airs semble simple ce
sont les mouvements du corps qui guide
la trajectoire le pilotage donc c'est au
tour la droite pour la gauche on pilote
avec les épaules on monte
et en baissant tout simplement en
accéléré avec la tête le poste de
pilotage
il y aller
sauter d'un avion permet de mieux gérer
les erreurs d'abord on saute de plus
haut à la dérive il n'y a pas d'obstacle
et ils ont deux parachutes en saut de
falaise il n'y a pas de parachute de
secours
il ne servirait à rien les pilotes ouvre
à 150 mètres du sol
si bas qu'il n'aurait pas le temps de
l'activé un risque qui freinent même
fabien l'instructeur du feu la wii sud
bien sûr je serais tenté d'aller jouer
avec le relief mais le fait de ne pas
avoir de joker dans mon sac ne pas avoir
ça vole de secours d'avoir qu'une seule
wallah l'ouverture c'est vraiment le
point technique qui me freine ainsi à
l'ouverture ça se passe mal hélas pas
neutre je suis père de famille d'une
petite fille de 2 ans et demi
donc même si j allais je pense que c'est
ma femme qui seraient pas d'accord
à 4000 mètres d'altitude c'est le moment
d'y aller
mathieu rate son départ il fait un roulé
boulé dans les airs mais se rattrape
bien le but n'est pas de volet très loin
mais d'apprendre à se stabiliser
grâce à ses ailes le vol dure une minute
trente
soit deux fois plus qu'un saut en
parachute normal
les travaux
excellent c'est génial on apprécie le
saut dire plus longtemps c'est la sortie
je parle ont perdu avant de voler avec
la combinaison des pros le club impose à
mathieu une vingtaine de seaux avec la
combinaison de débutants
s'il veut sauter d'une falaise cela
nécessite une expérience de plusieurs
années
fred et vincent ont plus de trois mille
sauts à leur actif en wingsuit et ce
sont des perfectionnistes genou tout le
cas des roms derrière avec ses petites
caméras embarquées ils analysent leurs
performances à chaque fois eux aussi
aiment s'amuser à frôler les rochers
c'est bon de l'ombre
cette fois ci ils ont plané à seulement
trois mètres du sol
sortie quand on se déplace en l'air avec
des mines qpr et au les sensations sont
sympas mais quand on a des références
par exemple des sapins ou des pentes ou
des falaises qui se déplacent ça donne
encore plus l'effet de vitesse et les
films déplacement donc aller évidemment
que c'est grisant et on a envie de se
rapprocher mais quand on est près du sol
le moindre mouvement
il faut être super précis donc il faut
pas se laisser aller trop bas si on
n'est pas sûr d'être d'être 100% précis
dans ces virages donc mais quand même
d'être à trois mètres du sol c'est
maintenant c'est dangereux quand on sait
pas ce qu'on fait mais je veux dire
c'est comme si vous dites un conduit un
pilote de formule 1 était à 250 dans le
virage c'est dangereux il va dire bah
ouais mais bon ça fait 15 ans que je
m'entraîne donc je sais ce que je fais
quoi donc c'est un peu pareil avant
d'arriver à ça il ya quand même un gros
travail de préparation
fred et vincent sont jeunes mais ce sont
déjà des vieux routards du ciel
[Musique]
pendant six ans en équipe de france de
parachutisme
il règne dans leur discipline
le free fly l'acrobatie aérienne
ensemble ils remportent trois fois le
championnat du monde
quand il arrête la compétition en 2009
ils continuent leur sport mais cette
fois ci en se jetant du haut des
falaises
on appelle cela du pays ce job de la
chute libre
mais cela ne leur suffit pas alors ils
adoptent la green shoots
aujourd'hui ils sont reconnus dans le
monde entier
il lui est exclusivement de leurs
passions leurs sponsors les payes pour
parcourir la planète et faire des vidéos
avec leur logo
et c'est aussi un peu grâce à eux que ce
sport extrême évoluent les fans zunino
et designer de wingsuit il conçoit des
combinaisons que fred et ses amis tests
en conditions réelles
si c'est le spot avant de les mettre sur
le marché
qu'est ce qui l'a fait petit accrochage
sur un apéro s'arracher les ipr ça fait
mal au coeur pascal et silvio non mais
la combinaison était déchirée parce
qu'elle a été accroché sur un
atterrissage mais c'est jamais en vol
qu'on verrait ce genre de choses
heureusement on va casser la culture
c'est dans ce petit atelier avec ses
cinq machines à l'ancienne que stéphane
professeur de parachutisme et couturiers
autodidacte invente les prototypes qui
vont faire voler fred
dernièrement il a mis au point cette
toute nouvelle combinaison
deux journées de bras non maintenant g7
plus qu il a rajouté de la surface de
tissus et utiliser une nouvelle matières
plus légères et plus lisse pour tenir
encore plus longtemps en l'air la wind
surf ses récents comme discipline et ça
évolue en permanence donc il ya tous les
six mois des motifs des trucs qui avance
et du coup ça bouge ça bouge tout le
temps quoi c'est un laboratoire
permanent
le but c'est de ressembler au maximum à
une aile d'avion pour cela stéphane créé
des entrées d'air qui rigidifie la
combinaison quand le vent s'y engouffre
des évolutions technologiques qui ont
permis en quelques années d'augmenter la
distance parcourue dans les airs en
partant de très haut
certains peuvent voler sur près de 10 km
les wings ute valent entre 700 et 2500
euros pour le modèle avec parachute
intégré mais il faut la changer tous les
deux sens aux pieds nus donc en tant que
testeur fred ne paye pas le matériel
et pour éviter les accidents il doit
s'entraîner sans arrêt d'un florence tu
passe derrière
contrairement à beaucoup de maires
josette n'a pas peur de voir son fils
prendre des risques
elle est même sa première fan
bois reymond this moment de la campagne
et de la comparer à n'importe quelle
heure à une demande je viens
c'est elle et son mari tous deux
parachutistes confirmés qui lui ont
transmis le virus
c'est au sa naissance on est partisan
des terrains il a passé tous ses
week-ends sur les terrasses utilise mais
voilà il a été bercé dès la naissance
il est tombé dedans comme obélix alors
séoul c'est là où tu vois l'endroit ya
un petit toit en fait pour être cette
phase blanche là et puis y'a un p'tit un
petit des verts sur le oui le petit oui
oui oui les petits des verts
ça vous fait quoi vous dire que votre
vivacité de la ola je trouve ça génial
moi je trouve ça beau c'est beau de voir
partir comme ça en wingsuit en tant que
maman vous n'avez pas une petite après
un petit truc un petit pincement mai
mais je fais confiance
j'ai confiance elle a l'habitude
maintenant le plaisir des passes
l'enquêté voilà on y voit là faut pas
traîner parce que je sens que je sens
faut pas traîner ça peut évoluer mon
coeur puis accompagnée de sa soeur fred
presse le pas il a peur que la météo
change rapidement battu sans le petit
vent là parce que le vent ça peut être
dangereux pour l'atterrissage
comme j'ai même pour le sol donc on y
vend trop de vent pourraient lui faire
perdre le contrôle de sa combinaison
comme ce pilote
malmené par les bourrasques
le danger de se faire plaquer contre la
paroi rocheuse
[Musique]
ça monte un peu raide après une heure de
marche
ça c'est le point de départ il appelle
sa mère 900 mètres plus bas
pour vérifier qu'il peut sauter en toute
sécurité ouais c'est moi il ya du vent
pas en bas oui mais il vient de derrière
donc ça c'est pas un souci mais en
battue sans rien quoi ouais c'est bien
ce que je pensais ok monique fauteux une
dernière photo pour l'album de famille
avant de s'élancer enfin qu'on arrive au
bord et qu'on voit que ça le fait bon
ben j'ai hâte d'y aller j'ai envie de
voler là je suis excité je suis un peu
impatient deux mois je fais ça pour
vraiment pour me faire plaisir donc je
prends pas de plaisir à avoir peur donc
si je me sens pas si j'ai peur c'est pas
un sou que je vais apprécier quoi on
avance et qui fait
c'est une drogue dure
[Rires]
ils sont près de 10000 dans le monde et
seulement 300 en france à être accro à
ce sport
une pratique qui fait rêver mais réservé
à une élite